good afternoon you all know by now that
algorithms are unfair there are a lot of
reasons that algorithms are unfair
sometimes they've been trained on
unrepresentative training data and this
is a picture of joy bulla meaning in the
middle of a demonstration of the fact
that a face tracker couldn't see her
face until she put on a white mask they
can also be trained on biased training
data so the data may have people from
many different communities it may be
representative in that sense but the
historical judgments and decisions that
have been applied to those people in the
past and are recorded in the data embody
historical biases so this is another way
that unfairness especially when
algorithms are trained on these data
comes in to the algorithms there's also
the question of the choice of features
that are being used in an algorithm in
order to make judgments and decisions
about people for example college
admissions decisions that are based on
AP classes are in some sense inherently
discriminatory against people who come
from poor school districts who do not
have access to AP classes and don't have
a way to prove their their their their
unique gifts and these have algorithms
can have life-altering consequences they
show up in mortgage terms where it's
just money it can be something even
possibly greater detention and release
decisions medical assessments and care
and university admission
now tell them we'll like this you know
it's not a surprise that algorithms are
biased data are biased the people who
build the algorithms are biased the
people who are choosing the features are
biased it's not even always a question
of evil but there's a tremendous amount
of hand wringing and there's paper after
paper saying we found bias here we have
found bias here we have found by us here
what are we going to be but there's not
that much work really on trying to fix
it it's one thing to notice it be
another thing that could be very
interesting to explain why is it that
the face trackers actually failed to
generalize from white faces to black
faces that's a very interesting question
I'm not sure I've actually seen anything
written on exactly that topic but anyway
so we want to try to actually do
something about it so a long time ago we
started working on basically trying to
design a theory of algorithmic fairness
and the general idea of this of course
that we have a diverse population with
many different axes along which
divisions are often created and somehow
or other the concern is a kind of
differential unfairness and so our
approach was to sort of follow the
wonderful paradigm from cryptography of
defining things very carefully than
building algorithms that satisfied our
definitions and proving theorems about
composition and that was kind of the
general plan and it's really really hard
so one reason that it's hard you can see
even in definitions so first of all what
would be a good definition of fairness
this tremendous amount of disagreement
just to give you an idea not you know is
affirmative action fair many people will
say yes some people will say no in some
context yes in some context no but also
usually when people think about fairness
like at the first shot they think in
terms of groups so a group fair
condition is a kind of statistical
requirement about how a group is treated
as a whole but the group fairness
conditions don't necessarily get at
something that many people feel is very
important which is an individual sense
of fairness I want to be treated fairly
I don't care you know I am NOT consoled
by the fact that my group as a whole is
treated well I want to be treated well
and I want to be treated in an unbiased
fashion so group definitions can be
problematic like they they they they
don't necessarily guarantee notions that
even anybody would think we're fair you
can point to some examples they fail
under scrutiny and also many natural
group fairness criteria are mutually
exclusive so so you can't have all the
natural things or even three of the
natural things that you want
simultaneously on the other hand if you
try to develop a notion of individual
fairness which says intuitively that
similar people should be treated
similarly you have the problem of
needing a task specific metric that says
for this particular task how similar are
these two individuals and where are we
going to get that information from the
historically biased training data I mean
where is our access to ground truth okay
so nevertheless we persist and there are
several veins of work on this topic and
I'm just gonna name a few of them and
clearly there isn't time to say anything
in detail so one really interesting vein
in the machine learning world is to
somehow learn a fair representation of
the data so these are very group based
notions and the idea is that you have
data that lives in some space and you're
going to transform and learn some kind
of an encoding of the data that somehow
stamps out sensitive information but
retains sufficient information to permit
standard
a different direction is so the learning
of a fair representation really is still
looking at group notions it's a
different direction that's been taken by
a collection of authors on this that
kind of aims for somewhere in between
the group notions and the individual
notions and these are requirements of
fairness or calibration so calibration
is this idea that is very standard in
statistics say for weather forecasting
which says essentially that if you if
you look at all of the days for which
you predict 70% a chance of rain in fact
in 70% of the cases it should actually
rain and this should happen sort of for
all values of 70
so these works look at fairness or
calibration for very large numbers of
large overlapping groups so it's not
enough that the answer should be
calibrated on their own but for all of
these groups simultaneously you should
have calibration the fairness results
leverage some kind of access to a
fairness consultant calibration results
rely on data samples from the real world
and another direction is to look at
various exploration versus exploitation
techniques when experimenting is
possible so that you can learn about
populations about which the algorithm
does not yet know much then there's
another vein which is causality based
reasoning where you try to rule out
effects quote/unquote caused by being a
member of a minority group and that also
is a group notion there's work on
composition and
which turns out to fail abysmally for
reasons that you don't necessarily
expect at all and also evolution if you
if you make decisions you end up
changing your underlying distribution on
people like if you make decisions about
who gets educated and how that changes
the population distribution of educated
people and their children and so how do
these things evolve over time as another
direction of research and finally very
recent work is leveraging human Oracle's
that are answering very few questions
that are difficult for humans to answer
to build one of these metrics so that we
can actually have individual fairness so
this is a collection of veins of work
and in the summer we have a cluster
that's organized together with Sampath
Kannan and Jamie Morgenstern we'll have
about 20 or 25 researchers including
founders of all of these directions
these veins of information and students
and there will be two workshops one of
them will be a traditional Simon's
workshop on technical advances in the
field organized by amar Lokhande or and
Wu
and then this love of my life which is a
cross-disciplinary workshop on racial
bias in data organizing with Patricia
Williams a professor of law at Columbia
and this will have people from
population genetics biostatistics
history of science African American
Studies philosophy and law and some of
the kinds of topics of the talks will be
as listed here which are sort of
different I think than what we usually
[Applause]
so human oracle the idea would be to try
to build a metric for certain kinds of
classification or scoring functions
using as a metric a person who is very
knowledgeable and very well trained and
the kinds of difficult questions for
such a person would be how similar or
dissimilar are these two people the idea
is to use an easier form of question
which is among who is closer to a either
B or C this tends apparently according
to the people who study these things in
HCI this is a much easier question for
humans to answer so the idea is to try
to have very very few difficult
questions and and leverage what you can
do with easier questions another kind of
an easy question is describe somebody
who is far from this person
alright thanks again
[Applause]